on thursday night president joe biden
gave a speech on the battle for the soul
of the nation and in biden's defense he
never specified which side of the battle
he was on
the speech was delivered in the ominous
dark at night
with the building behind him lit up in
an ominous red light with two marines in
silhouette behind him forced to stand
there on guard as biden scapegoated half
the country
as not only the cause of all of our
national problems but indeed as posing
an existential threat to the future of
our democracy just by our very presence
virtually every conservative and even
many libs are describing this speech as
a huge mistake needlessly provocative
even even just from the standpoint of
aesthetics downright cartoonishly
hitlerian
the second two points are correct but
the first point is off because the
speech was not a mistake
the darkness the rhetoric even the beer
hall push gesticulations they were all
intentional biden wants right wingers to
be provoked to violence he is
practically begging us to do an
insurrection we didn't do an
insurrection last time they really
wanted us to do an insurrection they're
really trying to get us to do an
insurrection now because with the
perfect record of failure that biden and
the democrats currently have with his
poll numbers on everything issue by
issue down in the doldrums the only way
that the libs can even hope to stop the
electoral bleeding come november is to
double down on their tried and true
strategy of encouraging blood in the
streets i'm michael knowles that's the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment on thursday boy it's been a
while was from christian thompson who
says the next time that kjp calls half
the country an extreme threat to
democracy peter ducey should ask her if
she can define democracy she won't be
able to this is a really great point and
you shouldn't just use it with green
jumpier you should use it on every lib
you know my pal matt walsh had this
wonderful rhetorical trick which is that
whenever someone would talk about
transgenderism and say trans women or
women he would just say what is a woman
he turned that little joke into an
entire movie we should do exactly the
same thing with democracy because
the libs
in the way that they are using the word
democracy cannot have a
real definition of democracy they can't
come up with it because they're saying
that when the majority of people vote
for trump or bolsonaro or victor orban
or any right winger when the majority of
people vote for a conservative
that that is a threat to democracy which
is ultimately self-under money always
ask like what is democracy what is it
maybe that will be my next movie i will
have to say when i want to get back to
basics in america okay i don't just
think about our political institutions i
don't just think about the star-spangled
banner and the red white and blue
you know what i sometimes i think about
going out and grilling on the 4th of
july and when i want to go grill some
good food i check out my pals at good
ranchers right now go to
goodranchers.com knowles regardless of
what this administration calls a
recession americans are worried food and
gas prices are higher than they've ever
been certainly in my lifetime i think
just ever which is why i'm so grateful
for my favorite meat delivery service
good ranchers while grocery store meat
prices continue to rise good ranchers
inflation-proof model locks in your
price the day you subscribe for the life
of your subscription so i've got to just
pause it there for a second
because it seems unbelievable
yes not only are you getting extremely
inexpensive very very high quality meat
but when you subscribe you just lock in
that price
forever for the whole length of the
subscription by the way you can pause
your subscription for up to 90 days or
cancel anytime you want
you're not going to want to you don't
want to keep it 100 american meat
born raised and harvested in the u.s
goes right to your door their beef is
prime or upper choice
the two highest grades superior
steakhouse quality i just absolutely
absolutely love these guys right now
when you go to goodranchers.com slash
knowles use code knowles kwles at
checkout you will get 30 bucks off plus
free shipping you can subscribe to lock
in your price and recession proof your
meals for life that's goodranchers.com
knowles use code knowles at checkout
i'm going to fly through this biden
speech but i really want to hit some
points here that i have not seen
anyone else not other conservatives not
really anybody else talking about this
speech
the biggest mistake
that the conservatives are making here
is that they're calling it a mistake
yes it didn't test very well yes in the
short term it looks really bad for biden
and the democrats the speech was not a
mistake the whole thing
the setting the rhetoric the arm
movements all of it was scripted all of
it was intentional why
why because the people who are who are
deciding joe biden's political
operations think that it will help them
in november and moving forward
this was the most significant
presidential speech of my lifetime it
was not the best
it was not the most virtuous it was not
not the most honest but it was the most
significant
this was
as close to a declaration of war on half
the country as i have ever heard from an
american president ever throughout all
of history
frankly abraham lincoln was was more
accommodating and was softer on the
secessionists than joe biden was on
ordinary conservative republicans
abraham lincoln had malice toward none
in charity for all
joe biden malice for half the country
charity for absolutely nobody he opens
up the speech
by setting the stage he says we are here
in this place for a reason
i speak to you tonight
from sacred ground in america
independence hall in philadelphia
pennsylvania
this is where america made its
declaration of independence to the world
more than two centuries ago
with an idea
unique among nations
that in america we're all created equal
this is where the united states
constitution was written
and debated
this is where we set in motion
the most
extraordinary experiment of
self-government
the world has ever known
the location is important it's not just
because pennsylvania is a toss-up for
the senate seat though that's part of wh
why joe biden showed up there the reason
why he showed up here though for this
national address and he says we're at
independence hall this is where america
began this is the home of the revolution
is because he's calling for a kind of a
revolution
his rhetoric is revolutionary rhetoric
he is saying we need to overthrow the
traditional american system and we need
to take half this country as we will
come to hear in the rest of the speech
half this country is a threat to this
country and we need to ostracize half
this country we need to suppress half
this country and we can't let half this
country have any say over where the
country goes he then there was a there
was a little point that i didn't see
anyone else notice but it shows you just
how radical the cultural revolution on
the left is joe biden it placed his
speech in history in the long march
toward greater liberty
and equality
and freedom for all listen to how he did
it
we the people
are burning inside of each of us
the flame of liberty
that was lit here
at independence hall
a flame
that lit our way through abolition the
civil war
suffrage
the great depression
world wars
civil rights
did you catch that one bit in there
suffrage
so he says it lit our way through the
long march for civil rights through
through this through that through the
civil war through the depression through
the long march for civil rights through
the suffrage
suffrage dreaming suffrage we've had
suffered since the beginning of the
country suffrage just means the right to
vote what he's referring to is women's
suffrage during the progressive era in
the early 20th century
but he can't say women's suffrage
he can't say women's suffrage because
democrats don't know what a woman is
i promise you that was intentional this
whole thing was scripted out you never
hear woman suffrage referred to as just
suffrage the woman suffrage movement is
called the woman's suffrage movement
except now that the democrats have
completely sold women down the river and
deny that women even exist as a category
of being so now they've got to change it
to suffer it shows you how
radical that revolution has become then
he gets to the meat of his speech he
says you conservatives it's not just
that we disagree it's not just that you
want to take our country in a bad place
it's not just even to use obama's
rhetoric the conservatives are going to
drive america off a cliff no they're
saying that
the conservatives by their very presence
by their very existence here in voicing
their political views pose an
existential threat to the country
too much of what's happening in our
country today is not normal
donald trump and the migrant republicans
represented extremism
that threatens the very foundations
of our republic
now i want to be very clear very clear
up front
not every republican not even the
majority republicans are maggie
republicans
not every republican embraces their
extreme ideology
i know because i've been able to work
with these mainstream republicans
but there's no question
that the republican party today is
dominated driven and intimidated
by donald trump and the migrant
republicans
okay so there he contradicts himself
right he says
listen the mega republicans they're the
threat but they're not the majority of
republicans i've worked with and first
of all if you just look at the polls yes
they are the never trump movement barely
exists it is statistically not relevant
at all it's pretty much just bill
crystal and a handful of his friends
that come over for tea to whine about
the last seven years of conservative
politics but the vast majority of
republicans have at some point in some
way supported donald trump they are mega
republicans he's doing this because he
doesn't he doesn't want to come right
out and say half the country is evil but
that is what he's saying and then he
contradicts himself at the end when he
says look he starts out this these
maggot republicans they're not the
majority of republicans they're not the
mainstream
but they also dominate the republican
party and control the direction of the
party uh i don't think so you can't have
it both ways
so
why does he focus on mega republicans
one because he wants to vilify half of
the country without
totally admitting he's vilifying half
the country but two he wants to justify
the arrest of donald trump on february i
think it was february 21st
vladimir putin gave a speech in which he
laid out his justification for the
invasion of ukraine and he said it goes
all the way back not just to stalin it
goes all the way back not just to lenin
it goes so much further back in history
this is why russia has a claim on
ukraine and this is why in a
hypothetical world if russia wherever to
make a more direct territorial claim on
ukraine why that would totally be
justified three days later putin invades
much more of ukraine than he had
previously occupied
okay so he used that speech to lay the
philosophical
intellectual groundwork for the invasion
that happened not long thereafter the
purpose of this speech was to lay the
intellectual groundwork such as it is
when joe biden is giving it
for the arrest of donald trump every
move that we have seen from the fbi and
the doj
at the direction of joe biden's
political appointees if not joe biden
himself has been
to double down on investigating trump to
raid donald trump's home to push for
more investigations of trump's
businesses all in the late up to 2024
the direction that this is moving in is
an indictment of donald trump now it
might not happen because some judges are
now getting involved and saying hey you
can't do that hey we need to have a
special master come in and take a look
at this investigation hey this hey that
to obstruct and slow it down but there
is absolutely no question in my mind
whatsoever the purpose of the speech is
to justify the next move that the biden
administration wants to make that is to
arrest donald trump
it makes me think we need some personnel
changes over there at the white house
and when you want to deal with personnel
when you want to deal with hr you gotta
check out bambi right now head on over
to
bambi.com and type in michael knowles
under podcast when you sign up when you
are running a business you will get hit
with all kinds of strange scenarios
let's say an employee not showing up to
work on time maybe a wrongful
termination suit one complaint can
destroy your entire company the problem
is hr managers are expensive they can
easily cost over eighty thousand dollars
per year but with bambi you get access
to your own dedicated hr manager
starting at just 99
a month all of bambi's hr managers are
based in the united states they can
support the nuances across all 50 states
your manager is available by phone email
and real time chat to help you
effortlessly run employee onboardings
and terminations encourage good
performance and make sure your business
stays compliant with ever-changing hr
regulations with bambi's hr autopilot
you can automate the most important hr
practices such as setting policies
training and feedback in fact bambi
clients are four times less likely to
have a complaint filed against them go
to bambi.com right now type michael
knowles under podcast when you sign up
that is
b-a-m-b-e-e
dot com bambi.com type in michael
knowles
so after vilifying half the country joe
biden comes back out and he says look
look i'm standing here i look like i'm
at the beer hall putch okay i've got the
scary red behind me i'm raising my hands
up screaming half the country's evil
threat to democracy but
i want to be a uniter i want to be a
uniter not a divider i'm a president
there's no red america there's no blue
americans trying to do a stupid obama
impression he goes i'm a president for
all of america
well i'm an american president
not a president of red america blue
america
but of all america
and i believe it's my duty
my duty to level with you to tell the
truth no matter how difficult no matter
how painful
and here in my view is what is true
maggie republicans do not respect the
constitution
they do not believe in the rule of law
they do not recognize the will of the
people
listen i'm not
i'm not uh for red america or blue
america i'm for all of america except
for red america they hate the
constitution and they deny the will of
the people even though they're half the
people and but when they exert their
will that's bad and anti-democracy and
when our half exerts its will that's
pro-democracy not one america or two
americas it's just
it's just incoherent is what it is and
then he ratchets it up even further
again this is the point of the speech
this is why it was not a mistake joe
biden
is provoking political violence
and this is a
nation that rejects violence as a
political tool
we do not encourage violence
we are still an american that believes
in honesty and decency
and respect for others
patriotism liberty justice for all hope
possibilities we are still at our core a
democracy
and yet
history tells us
the blind loyalty to a single leader
and a willingness to engage in political
violence is fatal to democracy there is
no place
for political violence in america period
none ever
oh good i'm so glad to hear you say that
joe biden the only problem of course is
that your side is the only side engaging
in political violence it's the only one
i'm not even going to have a caveat here
it's the only side the blm riots that
burn the country down for eight months
and killed dozens of people the
congressional baseball game shooting
that almost killed steve scalise that
was a bernie bro who undertook that the
brett kavanaugh assassination attempt
that there was a liberal from california
who took a bus across the country to go
and murder brett kavanaugh because the
supreme court was going to overrule roe
v wade how did he know about that
because it was leaked by a liberal who
was working for the court and these
protests that were illegal were
encouraged by elected democrats
including by the white house all the
ones outside the justices homes because
maxine waters said go up to republicans
where they are in public at the
restaurants in the public square at
their homes where their children sleep
and quote push back on them and tell
them they're not wanted here the list
goes on and on we'd be here for three
shows if i just had to list the
incidents of political violence from the
libs over the last five years
okay it's all coming from his side
and then he has the temerity to look the
conservatives in the united states
there's no place for political violence
except blm
yeah there's no place for political
violence yeah except except for us when
we show up in public and push back on
you guys yeah and start shoving you and
attacking you and trying to assassinate
your judges
yeah what i mean is there's no place for
political violence from you you won't
you won't you won't do political
violence conservatives yeah you won't
come on
come on come on do an insurrection come
on do an insurrection that's what he's
saying that's the point of this every
time joe biden accuses his opponents of
something that is a confession that he
himself is doing it you see it not not
one breath later when biden starts
talking about the the sacred
responsibility of americans to respect
elections
democracy cannot survive
when one side believes there are only
two outcomes to an election
either they win
or they were cheated
and that's where the maga republicans
are today
they don't understand what every
patriotic american knows
you can't love your country
only when you win
an amazing statement it had it had to be
intentional because we know al gore
still hasn't really conceded the 2000
election al gore still insinuates that
he won that election was cheated and
that george bush was an illegitimate
president hillary clinton says it
explicitly she says that that was an
illegitimate election in 2016. and it
was the russians and it was the
macedonians and it was this and it was
the that and she was there she was
really elected stacey abrams running for
governor of georgia is still pretending
that she was elected governor of georgia
she's using explicit language
about that alleged election fraud no
evidence for it at all and then biden at
the end he says
you can't love your country
only when you win
michelle obama
in 2008 said
that the first time she was ever proud
of her country in her adult life
was when it elected her husband
michelle obama
introduced at the national political
level the idea that you should only love
your country when you win that's an idea
that came out of the obama
administration
now biden accuses the republicans of
doing that completely baselessly and he
goes back and he says listen i know i've
just vilified all of you and i've said
you're anti-american and half this
country is illegitimate but we need to
respect our differences
american democracy only works
only if we choose
to respect the rule of law and the
institutions that were set up in this
chamber behind me
only if
we respect our legitimate political
differences
now the key word to understanding what
biden means is the word legitimate
because on its face it doesn't make any
sense he's he's giving a speech about
how we shouldn't respect the political
views of half the country but what the
the point hinges on is this word
legitimate because biden has said that
the views of half the country are not
legitimate so they don't need to be
considered they need to be excluded from
our democracy they have no role in our
country
when he says that that we can debate our
legitimate differences what he's
basically saying is do we trans the kids
at age three or do we wait until they
turn four that's that there can be a
legitimate difference of opinion do we
trans the kids do do we
should we kill babies all the way up
until the moment of birth or should we
say hey only up until the day before
birth
that's the legitimate difference of
opinion the legitimate difference of
opinion is do we take in 3 million
immigrants a year or only two million
nine hundred ninety nine thousand nine
hundred ninety nine that we can have a
legitimate difference of opinion but if
you wanna talk about actual differences
of opinion on the way the country ought
to go
no we should we can't respect those that
would be a threat to our democracy
democracy would be a threat to our
democracy which in joe biden's mind just
means
liberalism and then in this extremely
gloomy ominous speech with the red and
the screaming and the you know he almost
slips into a prussian accent while he's
giving it he says
that we need to be optimistic
even in this moment
with all the challenges we face
i give you my word as abide and i've
never been more optimistic about
america's future not because it may be
because of who you are
we're going to end cancer as we know it
mark my words
all nature is but art unknown to thee
all chance direction which thou canst
not see after this doom and gloom fire
and brimstone we are going to come for
you our political opponent speech
he says but we need to be
optimistic we need and as he says
optimistic right on cue
you hear a siren in the background
because
because
the
the very structure of reality will not
tolerate that kind of preposterous
disingenuous hypocritical lie from joe
biden
doom and gloom and pessimism but we need
to be optimistic
i don't things aren't looking too
optimistic joe
and he he
ends the speech
on what i think was the people would
call it a gaff
i would call it a freudian slip
age is still to come will say we all of
us here we kept the faith we preserve
democracy
we heeded our work we
we heeded not our worst instincts but
our better angels there it is
we heeded our worst instincts that oh
wait whoops was i not supposed to
oh no no sorry i got confused we heeded
not our worst instincts there it is a
freudian slip where you say one thing
but mean your mother so that was the
biden speech okay red
screaming gesticulations were half the
country's evil and illegitimate now
coincidentally uh donald trump just gave
his first public speech since the raid
on mar-a-lago since the biden
administration raided biden's
predecessor and chief political rival
totally unprecedented so banana republic
kind of stuff and so
donald trump gets out there and he gives
his speech to his conservative
supporters
take a listen compare and contrast
fetterman may dress like a teenager
getting high in his
parents basement
but he's a raging lunatic hell bent on
springing hardened criminals out of jail
in the middle of
the worst crime wave in pennsylvania
history
hilarious as the whole speech was
hilarious
notice
donald trump's
red white and blue everywhere joe
biden's just red everywhere
dark red donald trump's red white and
blue everywhere joe biden's very dark
ominous donald trump's big smiley
bright lights everyone
joe biden's everyone yelling and angry
and fear half this country is a threat
to democracy donald trump's yeah you see
this fetterman guy he's totally nuts we
shouldn't vote for him you should vote
for the other guy because fetterman he's
going to be a bad politician
which one of those two speeches is more
in line with the american tradition
the biden hall putsch or donald trump
giving a campaign rally which one of
those two speeches
seems like the threat to democracy which
of those two speeches seems on the
lighter side
of the battle for the american soul it's
not even a question
and well you and trump is smart here
he's not taking the bait in in this
obvious provocation for political
violence he's just laughing his way
to november he's saying look we might
have the forces
right against us all right we might have
a lot of stuff to take on not just the
democrats but the whole deep state and
the whole the whole
fetid swampy establishment but we're
just going to keep our chins up we're
going to keep doing the right thing
we're going to we're going to hug that
american flag picture those two images
biden screaming yelling red all around
him donald trump hugging the american
flag kissing the american flag at that
speech during his presidency you got
those two images trump says we're going
to do that that's really going to be the
way we keep the faith that's going to be
the way if we are to keep our democracy
that's how we're going to do it
the clearest
evidence i think that the dems are
trying to provoke political violence now
just came out of the va just came out of
the veterans affairs administration the
biden administration va has just
responded to the dobbs decision
overruling roe v wade and to the
pro-life laws passed in the pro-life
states
and they've said we are going to perform
abortions
even in the red states
even when the red states pass pro-life
laws and there's nothing you can do
about it here's the rule
rule says that the pro-life state laws
are quote not founded in science or
based on evidence and state and local
laws and regulations that would prevent
va healthcare professionals from
providing needed abortion-related care
as permitted by this rule are preempted
va is taking steps to guarantee that
veterans and other va beneficiaries
abortion related care
uh anywhere in this country
so this this is a very clear attempt to
provoke some kind of insurrection civil
war or violence
in as much as now you've got the federal
government declaring war on the states
on an issue
that is frankly even more fundamental
than slavery the civil war breaks out
because of a disagreement between the
national government and the state
governments over an extremely
intractable moral issue
such as slavery
abortion is even more so
because slavery you're talking about the
nature of liberty to man and his rights
to it
with abortion you're talking about the
right to life which is an even more
fundamental right
and here you've got the federal
government saying okay the states you
want to pass your laws i don't care
we're going to go in and kill the babies
in your states anyway
what are you going to do about it what
are you going to do about it huh you're
going to do an insurrection come on
we've only got like 60 days to the
election come on do an insurrection
we're going to kill all the babies
we're going to
and we're going to give speeches in dark
red lights
do an insurrection
booger that's what they're saying that's
the whole that's what the speech is
about that's what the va rule is about
the libs want
violence
speaking of violence
a transvestite child rapist and murderer
has just made headlines not for
uh the murder or the child rape or even
the transvestitism he's made headlines
because he is now a
much appreciated
uh counselor
to left-wing lawmakers on prison reform
yes he is he is giving his advice and
testimony
on how to go easier on murderers and
rapists and transvestites in prison
this man's name is patrick trimble he
now goes by patricia he just penned an
article for the prison journalism
project
that aims to empower incarcerated
journalists by giving them a platform
he's a regular contributor to here he's
to this journal he wrote about preparing
a presentation for a class at missouri
university he was contacted by professor
of criminology he says quote it is not
unusual for me to be asked to write an
article or story about things in my
wheelhouse the things in his wheelhouse
by the way are murder and rape but
in his wheelhouse now they're talking
about how to
make prison easier on criminals i am
after all a transgender woman feminist
activist and advocate for the
incarcerated lgbtq plus community
uh he
he he added that one of his papers on
discrimination against queer inmates was
published by harvard by the lgbtq policy
journal at harvard just a few years ago
vice magazine wrote a sympathetic
article article on this guy so who is he
what did he do in 1978 he raped two
nine-year-old girls by approaching them
at a playground and playing games with
them with rope and then tying them up
and dragging them into the woods and
brutally raping them
then while he was in prison awaiting the
final verdict on the case
trimble
took one of his inmates who was
developmentally disabled turned him into
his slave in according to the reports
and then murdered him
and now he's the one giving all the
policy advice on on the real victims
here
the uh transvestite rapist murderers the
psychosexual killers they're the they're
when you really think about it you know
when you really think about it they're
the real victims aren't they and that's
why harvard is going to give this man a
platform
and that's why missouri university is
going to give this man a platform
and that's why left-wing policymakers
who want to go easier on the inmates
they're going to listen to this man
the reason i bring it up
is because i think the right is making a
mistake
the right
as
a rule decries victim culture we say
stop playing the victim i don't want to
hear about victims all you libs you just
want to be victims all the time and
that's that's true they do that uh-huh
that's true
the issue is not victimhood culture per
se though
or rather i'll be more specific the
issue is not
that the libs are identifying victims
the issue is that the libs are
pretending that the perpetrators are the
victims and the victims or the
perpetrators the issue is not that the
libs are talking about victims it's that
they're getting the victims wrong
but actually you have to identify
victims sometimes
it's essential to identify victims
that's how you correct injustices that's
how you pursue justice more broadly
what what we should be
responding to this insanity with is not
an idea that oh come on stop playing the
victim you you transvestite murdering
killer rapist what we should be saying
is no no you're the bad guy you're the
bad guy here
there are victims but the victims are
not you
they're your victims they're the people
that you victimized and you need to be
punished apparently much harder than
you're being punished like way harder
like
like strap him into the chair and let's
let the vault start flowing kind of
punishment
instead of
giving lectures
at harvard and missouri
university that's what we need here we
need to say no no we actually need to
ratchet up the victim culture
when we talk about the actual victims
like the nine-year-old girls or like the
developmentally disabled cellmate
this is what happens
so often on the right is that the left
takes some ordinary part of politics you
know let's say standards or something i
talk about free speech a lot put it in
my book speechless
they'll talk about standards or taboos
and then the libs will completely invert
them and then the right
will just throw their hands up in the
air and say oh no never mind i don't
want to talk about good or bad or right
or wrong or true or false i just we
should just
take all the limits off speech entirely
let's just let's just let's just throw
out
all of human nature let's just throw out
all of the rules of social standards and
taboos entirely wouldn't that be so much
better but that's not possible and so
what the what it essentially amounts to
is the right just surrendering and
conceding and then the libs get to
invert the culture well it's the same
thing with victimhood no it's not that
we need to totally run away from
victimhood culture we just need to
identify the right victims
and they're thereby the right
perpetrators and then punish the
perpetrators
harsher or more harshly in a more just
way speaking of transsexuals
and victims
there was a post went viral over the
weekend of some psycho quack doctor
uh named si sib dubbed
s-i-d-h-b-h
gallagher who's a miami plastic surgeon
who specializes in mutilating people
boys who think they're girls and girls
who think they're boys captioning a
picture on instagram with a very very
young woman whose breasts she just
mutilated and cut off and this this
doctor quote unquote said that smile
congratulations
this was posted by a
columnist at tablet uh sasha white who
who pointed this out just showed oh my
gosh can you imagine this post from a
plastic surgeon
another post from from the surgeon says
just realized i only get to eat four
teats next week with a crying emoji and
a crying laughing emoji
really really horrible stuff so
the way this relates to
the standards and the victim culture and
the speech codes and all of that is this
person needs to get canceled i know that
for years the right wing complained
about the cancel culture canceled
culture is bad i i never really thought
that i never thought it was bad to
cancel people per se you just have to
cancel the right people for the right
reasons like all societies do but
there's no question we got to cancel
this person right this person should
lose her medical license she should
probably be put in a straight jacket and
an insane asylum but short of that she
should never work anywhere again she
should not be permitted anywhere near
children anywhere near this field if
she's going to get a job it should be
doing manual labor ideally in a prison
yard but
it's certainly nowhere near any medical
instrument okay
that's the first part the second part is
she's a plastic surgeon and this is
something that
we haven't talked about nearly enough
with transgenderism we focus on the
intellectual and ideological side of it
we don't talk about the money side we
don't talk about the capitalist side of
it
plastic surgeons love transgenderism
and they push transgenderism because
they make a lot of money on it
big pharma loves transgenderism and
pushes transgenderism because they make
a lot of money on it okay there are
financial incentives here that are
really horrible that we should correct
from a political level so that
very powerful lobbies and institutions
and professions are not incentivized to
mutilate poor little sexually confused
kids
furthermore it ties into a broader issue
of plastic surgery culture
we live in a culture
that treats plastic surgery not just as
a way to
sort of restore some more normal form of
the body after say a horrific car
accident or a burning or you know a way
to kind of restore
one's uh sense of self we now treat it
as a way to take total control over our
lives and prod and prick and treat the
body as nothing more than flesh to
create our own ideal selves
that are really disconnected from who we
are
that's bad i mean that's kind of
kardashian culture the idea that you
take people who are already
sufficiently beautiful you take people
who just you know they they're they're
perfectly normal ordinary looking people
and then you say no you've got to blow
up the lips and you've got to do this
thing and you've got to inject this over
here and you've got to add this piece of
fat over on this side and then you'll be
happy then you'll then you'll be so
pleased no it's all just parts of body
dysmorphias and and body image problems
that are never going to make you happy
and in a way transgenderism is just
is just kind of the logical conclusion
of botox
it's just it's just the logical
conclusion of this idea that your
physical body has to be absolutely so
perfect this indulgence of vanity and
vain glory and and this uh this idea
that we ultimately ought to have total
control over our own bodies and destiny
which is simply not the case because we
are stewards of ourselves but we we
don't belong entirely to ourselves we
are responsible to a transcendent moral
order and ultimately to god who is the
author of that moral order are you
speaking of gods i was talking about the
real god but there are sort of lower
order you know entities one of which is
the god king who runs the daily wire are
you still giving your money to woke
razor companies that hate your values
and see manliness as toxic and think you
should teach your daughter to shave her
beard there is a better way
jeremy's razors 100 real 100 woke free
100 fabulous the premium matte tungsten
handle has more heft than the left
the razor head pivots without caving
it's got six blades that are sharper
than truth
when you buy jeremy's razors you are
paying the salary of whoever wrote this
copy because i really like this
marketing copy and you're not just
making jeremy richer you're making the
woke left poorer which i love i like a
nice bit of kind of vindictive marketing
75 000 people have already made the
switch you should too go to jeremy's
razors dot com get your founders series
shave kit today jeremy's razors.com
jeremy's razors shut up and
shave
speaking of
cancellations
instagram this is really really great
news in the culture instagram has just
banned pornhub so rarely do we get good
news on the culture front especially on
the sexual revolution front this is
really great news instagram just totally
canceled
pornhub three cheers for cancel culture
that's my kind of cancel culture baby
but no pornhub's a private corporation
and they have no they don't they don't
have any rights actually but no i don't
think it's fair that they show it's
totally fair get rid of them totally
send whoever runs pornhub
send that person away to an island far
far away from our country because they
are harming
our country
instagram removed pornhub after mounting
evidence of alleged criminality
uh
that that has been stacking up against
pornhub
this according to the national center on
sexual exploitation
uh pornhub has recently been canceled by
visa and mastercard
um
and that's that's because of this claim
of you know sexual trafficking and child
pornography and all sorts of stuff on
the platform
so it's good i'll take the win when i
can get it
but
the reason to cancel pornhub is not just
because of the child pornography and
it's not just because of the rape videos
and it's not just because of a lack of
consent the reason to cancel pornhub and
the reason why it would still be legal
today to cancel pornhub just based on
obscenity and the reason why we've had
laws against obscenity for our nation's
whole history even though lib insane
judges have really tried to weaken those
in recent decades
is because
pornhub and porn generally provides
nothing of value
it only it only deprives you of value
pornhub
simply preys on people's lusts and
addictions
this is like any other kind it's like
the drug peddler around the corner in
the bad neighborhood
it's like the the mafia running the
numbers and the loan sharks and the
people
and and even legal casinos that are
preying on people's addictions and if
there are not safeguards in place
as they're
as they're often or not when it comes to
drugs and as there are often or not when
it comes to gambling and as they're 100
certainly are not when it comes to
online pornography if there aren't any
kinds of guardrails in place
it's it's just a
vile path to destruction for the
individual and for a whole country we've
got to take it seriously i know that
sometimes the the pro-porn people they
say oh you're just being fuddy-duddy
you're being prudish come on man it's
all right it's not so bad naked ladies
on the internet whatever and they're
pretending that this is you know been a
just a constant theme throughout human
history
it's not lust is a constant theme
prostitution is a constant theme
even
naked paintings and photographs is a
constant theme
this kind of
connected internet high speed porn
everywhere all around the globe with no
that's completely brand new we've never
seen anything like that it's just over
the last 20 years and it's why my
mailbag is filled up every week with
young men and
actually young women somewhat often as
well writing in about how porn has
ruined their lives and they were exposed
to it when they were little kids and you
just get just get rid of it that's it it
doesn't provide value when i go out if i
sell the leftist tiers tumbler at which
i do if i'm selling the leftisters
tumbler i am selling your product you
have to pay whatever it costs for the
leftist year's tumblr and we've now had
an exchange of value because now you you
know i i get your money and you get a
vessel to collect all the leftist tears
which is everywhere otherwise you know
it could you'd get too much salt on your
property and you wouldn't be able to
grow tomatoes anymore that's that's why
you need the leftist years tumbler and
then you can direct it down your gaulet
and enjoy those those leftist years so
we're we're each getting something of
value when it comes to something like
porn
or heroin or whatever or any sort of
vice you're you're not getting
any sort of real
deep vice and there's it's just gravely
simple in and of itself
you're not getting anything of value and
so it's wrong it's wrong it's wrong to
be involved in that anyway the models
are a problem too okay and the
advertisers are a problem too and the
credit card companies are a problem too
and instagram which gives porn have a
platform that's a problem too and
they're beginning to realize that and
they're going to cancel it and that's
great we should cheer on that canceled
culture
you know how big a problem this is it's
even affecting celebrities
it's even maybe that shouldn't be so
surprising but to my mind it often is
when people who are super rich and
famous and have all the resources in the
world when they fall prey to the same
sorts of problems and addictions and
vices that ordinary people fall prey to
it's just a reminder that this kind of
how potent this is you can't buy your
way out of certain addictions very often
it's the the celebrities who most easily
fall prey to addictions drinking and
drugs and promiscuity and all of that
well kanye's just saying that too kanye
just gave an interview he said that
pornography ruined his family
it was a little vague on how pornography
did that
he says
he was
writing on instagram about his daughters
and sort of to his daughters
don't let chris jenner
you know the mother or the matriarch of
the kardashian family
don't let her make you do playboy like
she made kylie and kim do hollywood is a
giant brothel pornography destroyed my
family i deal with the addiction
instagram promotes it not gonna let it
happen to northey in chicago
my kids will not do playboy and sex
tapes he then tells kim kardashian tell
your clinton friends to come get me i'm
here
so you say it's a little unclear here or
maybe he's just saying both things
because he's saying on the one hand
pornography destroyed my family because
i'm addicted to pornography right he's
saying i've dealt with the addiction but
on the other end he's saying pornography
destroyed my family because my wife was
was pressured into pornography by her
own mother the whole family was
pressured to be i mean that's ultimately
what got kim kardashian famous
was becoming a porn star and then she's
done other things since then but that
was her big explosion into fame and was
arranged by her mother apparently and
that's sick that's really really sick
and he's saying you're not going to make
my daughters do that
just like your mother made you do that
don't you dare do it
it's awful and and kanye's speaking not
just as a father wants to protect his
kids he's speaking as someone who has
dealt with an addiction to pornography
he's saying i've seen this issue from
all sides of it all of which is to say
and he gets to instagram specifically he
says
instagram's promoting it well not
anymore really really good stuff kanye
also made a really good point this is a
little tangential but i loved it so much
kanye said that the his the schools that
his kids are possibly attending
are really stupid and live and teaching
all sorts of crazy stuff he says they
teach black kids kwanzaa at sierra
canyon school
what the f is kwanzaa and who made that
bs up
everyone lives in la for the check
anyway so no one really cares about
their children being indoctrinated spot
on and now you know i give kanye a lot
of credit and i think that he's got a
more insightful view into politics than
99 of people including the vast majority
of republicans
he does in his own kind of weird kanye
way he does and he's really insightful
here too and he says
who the f made this bs up about kwanzaa
what are why are these socal crazy
teachers teaching this about kwanzaa
he's right
it was a lunatic southern california
teacher who invented it in the first
place ron everett in 1966
who restyled himself malana karenga but
his real name is ron everett he invented
kwanzaa
when he was a teacher at cal state north
beach or cal state long beach rather and
then a little later on he was arrested
for imprisoning and torturing women
had a pretty bad history but yeah
it's true it all comes from these
bizarre wackos in gamora by the sea
known as southern california
speaking of the academic establishment
by the way
i i saved this story until the end of
the show because this is going to get us
kicked off of
social media because i'm reading a
scientific study
and when we do get kicked off by the way
you got to come over for the member
block at dailywire.com we have the most
important interview that i have you know
i've spoken to attorneys general i've
spoken to secretaries of state i've
spoken to
united states senators regularly i've
spoken to people who carry a lot of
weight this is probably the most
important interview
i have ever given i will have ever given
certainly the one i'm most looking
forward to so tune in for that over at
the member block at daily wire but now
to get us kicked off
there's a new peer-reviewed study out
it's a study
conducted by flavio a category
he's board certified endocrinologist
with a master's and doctorate in
clinical endocrinology
is published in the online medical
journal curious
based on a controlled population study
of 88 012 people
in brazil okay enough of the lead
lead-up
ivermectin is apparently really good at
treating kovid
remember i ivermectin
okay i'm probably not even on youtube
anymore it's okay
ivermectin which we were told
it's not it's terrible at
curing covet it doesn't cure covet at
all it doesn't treat it it's horrible
don't say if you use the words
ivermectin if you use any word that
begins with the letter i you're going to
be kicked off of social media some
scientific misinformation it turns out
it's uh totally
totally true according to this study
regular use of ivermectin reduced the
risk of dying from covid19 by 92 percent
hospitalization rate was reduced 100
irregular users compared to both
irregular users and non-users by the way
the impressive reduction for regular
ivermectin users was evident despite the
regular ivermectin users being at a
higher risk of covid death in the first
place
told you so where's my nostradamus hat
where do i get it i don't even know
where i can find my nostradamus it's
back in my office in the other building
of course we were right
even if this study had never come out
even if the study has some error in it
which there's no evidence that it does
but even if it did
i have no doubt that this conclusion is
true and the reason i have no doubt that
this conclusion is true the reason i
have no doubt that ivermectin is more
than likely probably helpful at treating
covid is because all of the worst people
in the world who are wrong about
everything told me that ivermectin is
bad
so all of the worst people who got
everything wrong about covet and who
lied to us about covenant who lied to us
about everything all of those people who
have just an uninterrupted record of
failure came out against ivermectin so i
i never took an endocrinology
class in my life i didn't know the word
epidemiology until about four years ago
doesn't matter i just know i know with
certainty that ivermectin is more than
likely probably somewhat good
maybe even as good as it says in this
study maybe even as good as reducing
deaths by 92 percent from kovid and i
know that because
of a basic rule in politics
because i know my opponent
because in politics if you know the
enemy that can tell you a whole lot not
just about your enemy or your opponent
and their moves but about about just
about everything that they relate to in
the rest of the society okay was it
worth getting kicked off of youtube to
read that study i certainly think it was
but you got to go find me over at the
member block i've got
i've got
this interview i don't i don't want to
spoil it by even telling you who this
interview is with but the rest of the
show is continuing now you don't want to
miss it if you're not a member click the
link in the description and join us
[Music]
[Music]
you